- What's good Dubai?
(audience cheering)
What is good?
Thank you for having me.
Big shout out to everybody in the back.
I see you up there.
- [Man In Audience] Love you!
- Love you too.
Let's get into it.
All right, thank you.
So my plan here actually is
to do quite a bit of Q and A,
because the reality is,
the more I do this,
the more I realize how
simplistic my point of view
on marketing and entrepreneurship
and business actually is.
You know, I a lot of
times compare business
and entrepreneurship, and marketing
to working out or health.
You know, the reality is,
is trillions of dollars are being spent
on looking better, feeling better,
but the reality is, is
eating well and working out
at the gym everyday is the actual answer.
Yet, people are looking
celery or apple vinegar,
or surgery to execute that for them.
And the reality is, is that's
basically how I see business.
The reality is, it's
actually quite simple.
And more importantly,
for everybody in this room,
we are here during an
extremely special time
because this device is wildly underrated
by all of us in this room.
This is a far bigger deal than
I think we can understand.
How many people here are
older than 40 years old,
raise your hands.
So I'll raise mine.
So for the people that
just raised their hands,
you're aware because we lived
in the world pre-internet.
You're aware how remarkable
the internet actually is.
For the people in this room,
how many people under
30, raise your hands.
No concept.
You've had it so good.
Which is amazing, I love it.
The reality is is that it's
difficult for you even to know
how much opportunity you actually have
because you've only known
a world with the internet.
The internet is one of
the stunning, all time,
most important innovations
to hit the human race.
It has created a scenario
where I can be in New York
producing content on a
video and many people,
how many people here, by show
of hands, consume my content?
How many people?
(audience cheering)
For this many people to consume my content
at the volume of the
content that I put out,
30 years ago would have required me
to either buy a media company
for hundreds of millions of dollars.
Or, get lucky that I got chosen
to star in a show that went global.
It was inconceivable.
Yet, every single person here
can leave this conference
and make a video or a
picture, or write words
on two platforms right
now, LinkedIn and Tik-Tok,
have no awareness,
nobody knows who you are.
You haven't started yet.
Or if you have, you're bad at it.
And yet, TikTok and
LinkedIn, with no audience
will reward you and
have more people see it
because there's so many
people paying attention to it.
Yet, there's not enough
content being put in.
And so you get organic reach at scale.
When I see that it
reminds me of everything
I've ever done since
I've been a professional.
When I started building my
family's wine business for them,
it was email, it was Google Ad Words.
Later, it was Google
Search organic, for me.
And then, when my career
really took a different change,
it was YouTube and Twitter.
It was then Facebook, Snap, Instagram.
My friends, this has now been
going on for a long time.
And social media it's been
going on for over a decade.
The concept is very simple.
There's attention and
then there's what you say.
For everybody in this conference,
the key is to figure out
how they communicate.
Are you good at video?
Are you good at audio?
Are you good at the written word?
I promise you, for the
far majority of you,
the biggest breakthrough
you could possible have
at this conference,
is to figure out what kind
of communicator are you.
Because everybody aspires for video
because that's what we're
all paying attention to.
Yet, some people in here
are remarkable writers.
But, they shy away from it
because they don't think
that's the way to breakthrough.
They think there's rules.
Here's the rules.
If you're unable to
communicate you can't be heard
then nobody knows what you've got to sell.
Whether you're selling
funding for a charity
or running for government or a business.
Communication is the variable.
By the way, it's always been that way.
What's remarkable is every
single person in this room
now can do it.
My bigger question is, why aren't you?
There is no way that what I just said
is something that is so profound.
I think everybody here,
who here does not have a smartphone?
Raise your hand.
Good, nobody.
Oh really, is that true,
or you're just joking?
You don't have a smartphone?
Please come up here.
You're like, I wanna meet you.
Sir, please come up here.
Get up here.
(audience applauding)
Get up here, I'm not finishing the talk
until you get up here.
Dubai, this is an amazing
moment in our lives.
(audience laughing)
This man, does not own a smartphone.
It is more likely that
an alien comes from space
and joins me,
get up here, get up here.
Uh-huh, I believe it's
more likely an alien,
what's your name?
- Zien.
- Zien, so nice to meet you.
Let's clap it up for this legend.
Legend.
(audience applauding)
No smartphone?
You did have one at some point.
- I did.
- And how long ago did you get rid of it?
- 10 days ago.
- 10 days ago, why?
- I found myself wasting too much time.
And I was very distracted.
- Yes.
- And I find myself being
a lot more productive.
- Good for you.
- I get a lot more done.
I have people helping me.
And I...
- You're enjoying it.
You have a laptop.
- I send the email.
- You have a laptop.
- That's it.
- Yeah, good for you my friend.
- Thank you.
- It's a real pleasure.
Thanks for being here.
Let's clap it up.
(audience applauding)
Now, for the rest of us.
(audience laughing)
It's funny, this may be
interesting to a lot of you
because one of the things I
always talk about is patience.
I've been doing this a long time.
They weren't as big of conferences,
but I remember when I
was doing conferences
and I would talk about smartphones
and most of the room did not have one.
They had a pager.
You know, and how many
people here had a Blackberry?
Raise your hands.
Remember when you said you
would never get an iPhone
'cause you needed the buttons?
- [Audience] Yes.
- This is what I do for a living.
What I do for a living is,
I pay attention to people 24/7, 365.
For all the talking I do,
every minute you don't see me,
I'm listening, I'm watching.
People are very good at
saying what they won't do,
but I already know they will.
There are people in this audience
who right now in their head
say they will never get on TikTok,
and I know you will.
This is what I spend my time on.
Because, since I was a little child,
I have been chasing your attention.
When I was selling lemonade,
I didn't sell the lemonade,
I made the signs and I put the signs
on the trees and the poles.
When I worked baseball card shows,
I spent hours forming my table
to try to figure out how
to stop you at my table
not the person's next.
When I worked in my dad's liquor store
and I stood behind the register,
when I was supposed to ring up people,
I would watch people walk into the store
and would watch which
aisle they would go to,
what bottle they would grab, why.
It's why I read all your
DMs, and your texts.
Everybody gives me a lot of credit.
Gary you're so nice.
Thank you for replying, thank
you for liking, it's amazing.
No, thank you for commenting.
It gives me insight.
I understAnd I listen, I listen.
Here's what I can tell you about people,
the big things that are
happening in our society.
Number one, people value
time over everything.
Consciously and subconsciously.
Time, convenience wins
all the time, convenience.
We do not wanna do things that
we know can be done faster.
People talk about privacy.
We all give up privacy
every day for convenience.
Speed, speed, no friction.
Why do I produce content
on every platform?
Because I want you to consume
it how you wanna consume it.
You wanna listen to a podcast
while you run, I'm here.
You're a good reader and wanna
read on LinkedIn, I'm here.
You wanna put it on your
Apple TV and throw it up
and watch YouTube on your
television, I'm here.
Short, here.
Long, here.
No friction.
People sit around,
they have all these big ambitions
to be an influencer or
to build a big business
and then, the pick one platform.
And that's where they
spend all their time.
You know how many people here
would be in big trouble it
Instagram disappeared tomorrow?
How could you be reliant on one platform?
Tila Tequila and Dane Cook won on MySpace.
They didn't respect Facebook and Twitter.
That was a mistake.
YouTube, Snap, they ebb and
flow, they ebb and flow.
But like real estate,
but like real estate,
when there's a new platform
that has a lot of attention,
it's a good deal.
When you can buy beach front property,
you can buy beach front property.
It goes up if that area becomes big.
I spent an enormous amount of time
looking at under priced attention,
the way that people look at
under priced real estate.
I believe the current under
priced attention, in the world,
is LinkedIn and TikTok.
When I wrote, "Crush It,"
"Crushing It," excuse me, my last book,
the yellow one right there,
I just wrote that 18 months ago.
Not a mention of TikTok and LinkedIn.
Not a mention.
I, because I saw a lot of hands go up,
and that made me feel really good.
One more time, how many
people consume my content?
Thank you.
So, you guys know that I say
the same thing over and over.
I'm showing you videos
from eight years ago,
when I had a bad haircut
and was a little chubbier,
saying the same shit.
That will never change.
Hard work, kindness, caring
about your employees,
always thinking about the customer,
all them will stay the
same, forever until I die.
What won't be the same
is how important SnapChat
is, versus Facebook
versus YouTube, versus Instagram.
It always will evolve.
This is why I want you guys to
listen very carefully to me.
One of the most fascinating things
that have happened in the
world in the last 10 years,
is that real celebrities 10 years ago
made fun of YouTube celebrities,
Instagram celebrities,
podcast celebrities.
Real models, real models, seven years ago
made fun of Instagram models.
Until they didn't.
I'm gonna say something
that's very important to me
and everybody in this room,
creating content on social networks,
for everybody in this room,
regardless if you're part of the ministry,
whether you're in business,
to business B2B, whether you're B2C,
whether you're part of the government,
whether you're an individual.
For every person in this
room, from every angle,
from every person,
creating content on
social networks at scale,
is the single great
opportunity in our society.
And everybody in this room, everybody,
including me, will regret in
15 years, not making more.
Because you do understAnd
other technologies are coming.
You do understAnd that
when voice comes along
and Google Home, and
Apple Home, and Alexa.
When voice comes, we're not
gonna be looking at our phone
as much, just like that
gentleman realizes,
maybe I don't have to have it.
When you can say, Alexa,
where's the best restaurant?
Alexa, send me toilet paper?
Google, what's the weather?
Think about all the things
you go to your phone
that takes 25 seconds,
but Alexa can answer in two.
You will choose Alexa over your phone.
Remember I told you.
When we do that,
we will be reliant on your brand
not being discovered in explore,
or showing up third on Google.
This, is a very important
time in communication history.
The reason you're seeing things
like America and London, and India,
and all sorts of things
happening in the world,
different things that we didn't expect,
is because of communication.
Communication has always
been the forefront
of what happens in the world.
Almost every thing you believe right now
was put into your head.
By your parent, by a piece of content,
by something else.
My friends, please do not
waste this conference,
the fact that we have this time together,
to not let this be the time
that you finally hear me.
You've been listening to my content,
but you don't hear me.
but you don't live what
I'm telling you to do.
Why, because there's a much bigger thing
that's going on than what platform
you should post on or how often.
It's called, self esteem.
The single most important thing
that I think about these days,
is that I am blown away by the level
of insecurity there is in our society.
We have so much insecurity that Instagram
had to take likes away
because you're not capable of actually
talking about what you
actually wanna talk about.
You are so addicted to
other people's opinions
that you start posting only things
that you think will get likes.
Not what you actually want to talk about.
This is very important.
Thank you, it's very important.
(audience applauding)
I promise you the reason
that I stand on stage
is because the self esteem and parenting
that my mother put into my body.
Period, period.
The way she raised me
around putting kindness and hard work,
but also no entitlement,
not worrying about what people
said about me is imperative.
Let me tell you what the
biggest vulnerability
for most people here is about
social media and content,
you enjoy the cheering too much.
The reason this is an interesting game is,
you love it when you post something
and people say you look pretty.
Or that was a good shot.
Or you're funny.
Or that was brilliant.
You take compliments too high,
so when people come in
and say you look ugly,
or you're stupid, or you're wrong,
you take pushback too deep.
I and all the people that
I see who are winning,
don't take the compliments or the insults.
Everyday on my content,
there's comments that say,
you suck, you're a loser.
And the next one, you're god.
(audience laughing)
I don't get too high, I don't get too low.
My friends, you have to
leave this conference today
and figure out for yourself
how you are gonna post on social platforms
25 to 60 times a day.
Let me say it one more time.
That's right, and by the
way, I want you to do more,
but I didn't wanna scare
you too much Dubai.
I'm not kidding.
25 to 60 times a day.
What does that mean?
That's arbitrary numbers.
I coulda said 20 to 100,
I coulda said 80 to 150.
As much as humanly possible.
I didn't say you have to come up with
25 to 60 ideas a day.
I said, you have to make 25
to 60 pieces of content a day.
When you make an Instagram story,
maybe you save it and you got to Twitter
and post it and you write
a couple of extra lines,
and now you've made two pieces
of content from one video.
Maybe you take that video
and post it on YouTube
and write three lines of sentence,
now it's a third.
Maybe you take a still
shot and then draw over it
and it's your Snap,
and now you're on four.
25 across all platforms, right.
I want you to be on every platform.
All of them.
They go up, they go down.
They go up they go down.
But people don't go on platforms
'cause they don't have
a lot of followers on it
and they feel insecure.
So you stay on Instagram
because that's where
you have 7000 followers.
You don't wanna go on Twitter
or Facebook, or YouTube
'cause you only have 15 subscribers there.
And you feel like you feel sad.
The person in this room who decides
to stop listening to everybody else
is the person that's
gonna win this room today.
(audience applauding)
Right, you understand.
So that's it.
You know, I hate when people call me
a motivational speaker.
If you look at my content
from 2011, 12, 13,
I tried to do nothing rah-rah, or high up
because I didn't want that.
After I wrote "Crush It."
I'm a business man.
I'm a strategist.
I'm an executer, I'm an executive.
But over the last three years
I had to look myself
in the mirror and say,
I'm doing what I tell people not to do.
Because I don't want to
be a motivational speaker
and that's how people see me sometimes,
I'm not giving away the
best information I can give.
I was being selfish.
So over the last three years,
I've gone into these subject matters.
If you thought that I was ever gonna talk,
I never thought I was
gonna talk about parents,
or self esteem, or entitlement.
If you thought I thought five years ago
that I would ever make a
video that goes like this,
and this is for everybody,
if you're 22 years-old, or older,
and your parents give you
money, you're in bad shape.
You know what's funny,
I don't feel like you're a loser,
I feel like you're in trouble, mentally.
Because what is happening is
you're getting more insecure, not less.
You're getting resentful of your parents,
and I promise you,
your parents are resenting you.
I never thought I was
gonna make that content.
But that's the content that I watch for
when I see people take photos,
and by the way,
Dubai is a disaster in this.
When I click on Dubai,
every photo is private jets,
and Luis Vuitton, and Rolex watches.
I take a throw up on Dubai.
(audience applauding)
All I see, I don't see people
that genuinely enjoy the craftsmanship
of a Louis Vuitton bag.
Or the fact that it's a good shape
for their day to day life.
I see people that are so insecure
that they wanna show other people
that they're doing well,
and they use the logo to
make themselves feel good.
(audience applauding)
And for anybody who's in the crowd
who doesn't know me,
or is confused right now,
I do not come to this amazing place
to razz on people or hurt feelings.
I'm here trying to help.
This is the conversation that
we need across the world.
Good news Dubai, the same
thing's happening in New York,
and LA, and London, and Sydney,
and everywhere else in the world
that has a little bit
of money in the system.
We as a society have to
change the conversation.
No longer is it acceptable, in my opinion,
for humanity to put money on a pedestal.
(audience applauding)
Now, money's fine.
I don't wanna demonize money, go win.
But we have to put
happiness on a pedestal.
We have to.
Do you know how many millionaires I know
that are miserable?
Almost all of them.
We have to change this conversation.
Let me tell you why.
It's not sustainable.
People wanna blame suicide
and all the gun violence,
and all the bad stuff on social media.
Let me tell you guys something,
there is no social media.
Social media's empty.
We fill it.
We're social media.
Social media's not making
you bad, you're bad.
Social media is exposing us.
It's not changing us.
You're in control.
Not the phone, not Instagram, you.
And if you wanna get
rid of the phone, good.
And if you wanna limit your
time on Instagram, good.
And if you wanna stop looking at the likes
and post what you actually want,
or instead of exposing your
body for more likes, good.
You're in control, not them.
Stop blaming the machine,
start blaming yourself.
(audience applauding and cheering)
My friends, I can see it
in your collective faces,
you know I'm right, I know I'm right.
We all know it's right.
My question is, what are
you gonna do about it.
Do you have the courage to take the way
you're feeling right now,
and leave and go make a post
without the perfect lighting,
with no makeup, without the right angle,
and actually talk the truth?
Do you have that courage?
Because I promise you,
you will be much happier as a human being
if you start doing it, much.
Enough with filters and
angles, and glow lights.
(audience laughing)
Enough with guys buying
fake watches and suits.
You're tricking no one dick.
Tricking no one.
You're tricking on one.
(audience applauding)
this is a warfare of happiness
versus perceived happiness.
My friends, this is a warfare of happiness
This is the greatest
generation of perceived happy.
People are gonna go on
vacation this holiday season,
just for the Instagram photo
to send back for everybody to see.
Gonna go on a vacation they can't afford,
to make it look like they're successful.
Who else is tired of this bullshit?
(audience applauding)
We need to flip the world.
We need to flip this.
Both work, like again, it's
very important you hear this.
I'm a business man.
I'm trying to build huge businesses.
But I like the process of building it,
not what it can buy me.
Almost every fake entrepreneur in here
wants to start a business to
sell it, to buy something.
That's why you're not going to build it.
My friends, if you're
building a business right now,
and thinking about how
quickly you can sell it,
I can promise you, you already lost.
And this is all happening while
the economy is phenomenal.
This has been over the last 10 years,
when everything's easy.
This is the easiest time.
How many people here are
entrepreneurs or startup founders?
Raise your hands.
If you're one of those people
and your business is not crushing it
during this time, you suck.
(audience laughing)
And that's okay.
I suck at a lot of things.
I suck at tennis, I suck at school,
I suck at skiing.
I'm just telling you, as a friend,
if you just raised your hand
and you've been doing it for three years
and it's not annihilating it right now
during the easiest time in the
history to build a business,
you need to really go home
and look yourself in the mirror.
Because let me remind you,
being the number two or the number four,
or the number eight at Tesla,
or Facebook, or Instagram,
made a lot more money than the number one
of your bullshit startup.
This is about self awareness.
Do you know yourself?
This is about finally
having the conversation
that you need to have.
And you need to tell your mother or father
you're done living your life
based on what they want.
It's time for you to tell your spouse,
sister, brother, husband
that you're done living
your life for them.
Hardest conversation.
I do not stand up here
and say that so easily.
I just know it's true.
I don't think it's easy.
I don't think anybody's
picking up the phone call
and being like, hey mom, screw you.
It's hard, I got it.
I know it's hard.
But my friends, this
starts at an early age.
Do you know how,
everything I just talked
about, it's called high school.
And you're still in it.
We have to get out.
So that mindset is why you're not posting.
I'm posting so much 'cause I'm not scared
of what you're gonna say.
if it's not gonna hit the
same metrics as last time.
I'm posting 'cause I
have something to say.
I'm posting 'cause I wanna talk.
I'm posting 'cause I love
people and wanna interact.
But the majority is not.
People who say things like
but I don't know what to post,
are already stuck in the
judgment of the post.
Period, end of story.
The entire opportunity in your life
is writing words, making
pictures and making videos,
for 10 websites, on your phone,
at the biggest scale that you can.
It's happening right now.
This is the greatest
land grab of attention
in the history of mankind.
I have nothing else to say.
There's no system.
I have no products.
I have nothing else to say.
That, got do it.
(audience applauding)
That's it, that's what I got for you.
But the mindset, where
are the mics, real quick
'cause I wanna start doing Q and A,
if you've got, there's one right there
and there's one right there, great.
Guys, I'm about to go into questions.
It's goes slow and
you're probably not gonna
get your question in.
So if you wanna ask me question
you need to get in line,
you better get up fast bro, run.
Run, yes, faster, go.
You're going the wrong way dude.
Dude, you're going the wrong way.
(audience laughing)
You were first to move and
now you're like 11th in line.
- [Woman] Where is the line?
- It's over there, and over there.
I'm gonna go into Q and A.
But my friends, I really hope
you heard what I had to say.
Because all the tactics,
you know, like how do
we post, this and that.
I put that out for free.
How many people saw, two
weeks ago on my birthday,
I put out a 270 page deck for free.
Raise your hands.
Good, most of you didn't.
I put out, thank you.
I put out a 270 page deck for free
on how you make 64
pieces of content a day.
It's free, Google it, you'll find it.
Somebody will share it.
You'll figure it out.
And if you can't, you're
gonna lose anyway then.
If you can't find my deck,
you should leave you're
never gonna build a business.
Find that deck, consume it,
because that's gonna save
me talking about things
that are redundant, up
here for 30 minutes.
Let's get into the details.
But I just wanna tell you Dubai,
thank you so much for the hospitality.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Let's get into it.
- [Man] Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, thank you.
I authored a book when I was,
- [Gary] Can you guys make it louder,
on the mics, if you can?
Go ahead my friend.
Go ahead.
See, if somebody filmed
it, that's good content
on Tik Tok.
- Can you hear me?
All right, good.
- [Gary] Okay, go ahead bro.
- All right, so I authored
a book four years ago,
and basically I developed a concept
about the relationship between
the fundamentals of business
and human beings.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I wrote my book, I started
motivational speaking,
sales training around the world,
but then I came to a point,
my business was growing,
and then it wasn't sustainable.
I wasn't making enough money.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So, I had to stop, I left Australia,
I ended up getting an
opportunity in Dubai,
and now I work for the royal family
and I advice them on their investments.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I want to go back to entrepreneurship,
but the growth it was sustainable.
- [Gary] Why wasn't it sustainable?
- The money I was making, I just couldn't.
Like I couldn't--
- [Gary] Maybe you should of spent less.
- I mean, okay, we can look--
- I mean, that's fair, right?
- Wait, wait, no that makes sense.
I agree with you 100%.
- But, you mean you want to live
a more glamorous lifestyle than-
- No, no, no, no.
Gary, all that--
- [Gary] How much top line revenue
was the business doing?
- Nothing, I was just 12 to
$15,000 a month, give or take.
- [Gary] Respect, keep going.
- So, I'm not a brands guy.
I don't give a shit about that.
I care about my family,
I care about myself,
I care about, you know, that stuff, right.
- [Gary] It's awesome.
- So, I had put my business aside,
my book still sells on Amazon.
"Your Life Your Business,"
Patrick Osman, by the way.
Check it out.
Anyway, I need to sustain my family.
My brother, my mom, my dad.
They're my priorities.
They're my goals.
That's why I put entrepreneurship aside
and I'm now back into employment.
- [Gary] But you miss it, you miss it.
- It's in me.
- [Gary] Yeah, I love that.
- I'm an entrepreneur.
You're not listening to me.
I came to New York, and
I came to your office,
and security kicked me
out of your building
'cause I didn't have a meeting with you.
I was dying to see you,
about two years ago, dying.
They wouldn't let me in.
I did DM you.
I respect the fact that you got
thousands of millions of followers.
- I'm trying my ass off.
- I understand.
- And by the way,
I can tell your energy,
it wasn't creepy that you came.
I'm sad that I missed the DM
But here we are so let's talk about it.
Have you thought about starting
at a side hustle level.
Carving out two hours a day
that doesn't exist right now,
so you can start it.
And God willing, after two years
of two or three hours a day,
it gives you enough fire where you think
you can then make the flip and go there?
- But is god willing a strategy?
- No, God willing's a saying,
saying if you actually work
two hours a day every day,
and are smart, and bring
value, you may have a business.
But it's an important point,
because what I like about you,
and I'm sensing it very quickly is,
there's a level of
practicality and clarity.
I think the most practical clear situation
that you're dealing with is,
you've got something
you wanna do practically
for your priority, but you
want something for yourself
and the way to do that
is to actually do that for yourself.
You're just gonna have to put
in two hours a day at first,
'cause you don't have
the luxury to put in 15.
But if you nail those two hours a day,
by the way, my first book was just this,
and I have thousands and tens of thousands
of stories of people for four years,
doing it for one hour after work.
And then finally, something clicked
and they were able to make the switch.
This just requires one very
difficult thing, patience.
That's it brother.
And that's your weakness.
- It kills me.
- [Gary] I know.
- I respect that.
I've seen videos of you,
you say, it's not about what
you do from nine to five,
it's about what we do from five to nine.
And I admire that.
And that little sentence
has got me very far.
I've developed amazing things from that.
But the patience thing is
killing me, it's killing me.
- Bro, let me tell you why I'm tricky.
Let me tell you why I'm tricky.
I just realized this very recently.
I'm like, oh right, I'm
saying a lot of things.
I didn't realize you
had to do all of them.
It's like cooking a meal.
You might be good at the hustle part.
You might be good at understanding people.
You might be good at giving.
You might be good at
taking care of people.
But if you're bad at patience,
the whole thing falls.
If you're great at patience
but you don't have the
work ethic, it falls.
If you're great at patience
and the work ethic,
but you treat people bad, it falls.
I'm like, oh right.
This is why it's challenging.
You need to get all 16 ingredients right
to make this actually work.
And the patience, for the
ambitious, is the hardest.
Do you know how ambitious I am?
If I didn't have patience,
I was in a liquor store at 27 years old,
ringing up my friends at the register.
I had a patience.
My priority was my parents too.
I wanted to build them
a humongous business
for how they parented me.
I left that business at 34 years old.
I didn't have any money.
I started VaynerMedia in a conference room
in another company,
'cause I didn't have enough
money to pay for rent.
I was patient.
And I'm 44 and I haven't even started.
Bro, you got time.
How old are you?
- [Patrick] 27.
- I'm done.
I'm out, next.
I'm out, I'm out.
Yes.
- [Woman] Uh, Gary?
- Yes.
- [Woman] First, I just
wanna say thank you.
Three years ago I quit
my nine to five job.
I had 3,000 Dirhams in my bank account.
And when I made that
decision to quit my job,
it was a lot of it because I
was consuming your content.
So I have a lot to say.
Thank you, 'cause I quit my job
and now I have my own business.
It's only been three years.
But it's financially healthy.
I am so happy.
So the first thing I just wanna say is,
thank you, you mean the world to me.
More than you would ever know.
(audience applauding)
- By the way, by the way.
I'm sorry, apologize.
There's a lot of people
thinking right now,
let me tell you something
that is very real,
it's not for everybody.
But there is a very big
percentage of people in here,
that that admiration
is way more interesting
than making $100,000 today.
And if you're lucky that you're DNA
is similar to mine,
it's about providing
value with no expectation.
None.
- We love you.
- I love you too.
(audience applauding)
People say to me, Gary,
you're wrong, I give all the time
and I get walked all over.
I go, no you don't.
You're not giving, you're manipulating
because you're fake giving
and you want something in return.
Giving is only when you
expect nothing in return.
(audience applauding)
I don't want your seven day trial,
but then you sell me.
I don't want your free course
and then it actually is trying to sell me.
Giving is giving, period.
(audience applauding)
- Okay. (laughing)
So yeah, I just wanna
first say a huge thank you,
I love you so much.
You really, you are still playing
such a huge part on how
I'm running my business.
All of your advice, all of your content.
The practical advice that you give.
I really, my business
would not be where it's at.
And it's only three years, it's baby,
but it's financially healthy.
And I'm so happy, I worked my ass off
and Dubai is really hard.
I'm self funded, I'm
independent, it's just me.
- [Gary] So, what can I answer for you?
- Okay, it's been three years
I run my business here in Dubai.
And it's getting to a
point where I just feel
that Dubai doesn't really
have the infrastructure
that for an entrepreneur like
me, it's expensive basically.
It's expensive--
- [Gary] What kind of business is it?
- Social media marketing.
So I pretty much help people build
their own business and side hustles.
And it's just, the expensive
or running the business
here in Dubai now that it's
getting to three years,
I just feel that it's
just weighing me down,
and it's not making me feel happy anymore.
- [Gary] So move.
- And so, my question then is,
I know it, 'cause I
knew you would say that.
Alex, then just move.
But then what happens
when all of my businesses,
a lot of, like 80% of my
business is here, my clients,
- [Gary] Save money, save
money, move and do it again.
- Cool.
- You said the most important part Alex.
You said you're not happy.
- [Alex] Yeah, and I'm not.
- You were not happy in
your job, you quit it.
You made yourself happy.
Now, you're three years in
and you're not happy, so move.
The good news for you is,
unlike for a lot of people here,
you've already taken a jump once.
Do it again.
- And I'm happy here
when I'm with my clients
doing what I love.
- [Gary] I don't care.
- Okay cool. (laughing)
- That's a micro-happy.
You're macro unhappy.
Alex, you need to move.
See you Dubai.
- Thank you so much, love you.
(audience applauding)
- [Salmund] Hi Gary, this
is Salmund from Pakistan.
- How are you, so nice to meet you.
- [Salmund] I've been following
you since I was 25, 26,
and I just turned 30 fourth of November.
- You look great.
- I just didn't know,
after 30 what I will do.
I mean, you always said,
30 is the age when you start.
And there's zero that I feel that,
I haven't done anything yet.
But on the other side of the country
that I've done a few
other, a lot of businesses.
When ever I reach a point
that I know I can make it.
I just leave that thing
and I move on to another
challenge to myself.
- [Gary] That's good.
- Right, but the patience
thing is still there.
That's not a problem.
I do a day job nine to five.
- Is the age 30 freaking you out?
- I mean, it's just that I want to know
how would it start off at 30, the process.
That's thing I've not figure out yet.
- Bro, 30 means nothing.
I think 30s bothering you.
- Yeah, that's thing I think,
that I've been hearing too much.
- [Gary] Let me save you
time, 30 means nothing.
- All right, and just
another thing on this,
I just wanted to know,
I've been on many, all of
these platforms you talk about.
It's just that I've read
that medium is the message,
rather than the message that you give out.
So, I just wanted to
know your two cents on
what do you feel about the medium itself?
- I believe in context for the medium,
but the message is the message.
- [Salmund] Right, so
medium is the message,
or the message the medium?
- Both, but look...
You consume my content, where?
- [Salmund] All over, different places.
- You've answered your question.
- Right.
- Got it?
- Yeah, thank you, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
- [Fabio] Hello Gary, this
is Fabio Kalarani from Italy.
- How are you?
- [Fabio] Good, you?
- Well.
- So in 2015 I was broke.
I was living with my parents
with my wife right here.
She was sleeping in the living room.
We were trying to--
- [Gary] Your parents were conservative?
- No.
- [Gary] I'm kidding,
I'm kidding, go ahead.
(laughing)
- So then digital marketing saved my life.
- [Gary] Okay.
- In 2017 I decided to
give back to the world
so I created the biggest movement of
digital entrepreneurs in Italy.
With thousands of people
and they even make it stronger
with a movement called All Inners
with people that go all-in
and want to make it again.
So now I'm like you.
I created content every day.
Like for every platform,
we team editing the content,
making it for every platform.
- [Gary] Yep, good.
- But I would like to have my message,
go out there more organically
because even if I know the
algorithm of YouTube maybe,
like I know a little bit.
I know how to write keywords,
content, I'm a marketer,
I feel I'm going too slow, I
want to impact more people,
and they started in Italy
because I'm Italian.
- [Gary] I got it.
- But then I speak other two languages.
- Clearly.
- I want to impact the world.
So how will you help like give
me advice to grow faster--
- Two things, the quickest
way to not grow faster
is to want to grow faster.
Let me tell you why.
What worked for you was
something that mattered
and it caught fire.
Now that you want to grow faster,
you're trying to hack strategies
to make you grow faster in numbers.
The message is getting diluted.
- Yeah, because maybe I'm getting tired
on creating too much content.
The reality is that I'm getting tired,
I don't, bombarding the social.
- It's not that,
it's that your North Star
is to grow in numbers,
not to be thoughtful to come
up with new things to say.
- So what's your advice for me then?
- My advice is stop trying to grow faster.
- So take my time and--
- [Gary] And say things that matter.
- Yeah, without filter.
- [Gary] Correct.
- In your face.
- [Gary] That's right.
- That's what I do, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applauding)
- [Nadal] Hi Gary my name's Nadal, I'm 15.
- How are you bro?
- [Nadal] I'm good, how are you?
- Really well.
- So I currently run two businesses
however there's one business
that I'm currently struggling with
that includes sports cards.
- [Gary] Okay.
- So sports cards might
may be like big in the US
and Canada, however here in the UAE
I don't think anyone really--
- [Gary] Collects.
- Yeah
- Okay.
- So I've been trying
to talk to my friends
and send some companies there
and educate them about it
however I'm not really successful
in building a community for the niche.
- [Gary] how long have you tried to build
the community for the niche?
- Like two months.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
You know where I'm going, right?
I mean first of all you've gotta obviously
look at proper football
cards for this niche, right?
There's a much better chance,
like maybe basketball, definitely
not football or baseball
like this is gonna be a football market,
a proper football market.
It will happen here if it
continues to go the way it's going
because people are making a fortune on it
and a lot of people when they get educated
that they can make more
money in sports cards
than they can and
cryptocurrency and cannabis
will run towards your game.
You just need to stay patient.
You just told me that you're struggling
after trying to do
something for eight weeks.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
- [Nadal] Oh yeah.
- You got it.
- [Nadal] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Anything meaningful,
anything meaningful
takes a very, very, very,
let me get this straight.
You want to win life?
You want to live a 1% life
of being a millionaire
and doing anything you
want and being happy.
Don't you think that should be hard
and should take a long time?
- Hey Gary.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Good, how are you.
- [Gary] Super.
- First of all I want to say
thank you for everything.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- You've made a lot of
changing in my personality
and all the I don't know what you call it,
like drilling, ideas in my head.
It's just been crazy.
I've been working on it for long.
And another thing I want
to say the 180 cent rule,
it works, so everybody go for it.
I've been doing it for
three, four weeks now.
I've noticed not only growth
but that I can give some ideas.
I'm into calisthenics, so I went through
and sometimes I just say a great workout
or something like that but at another time
I'm giving really good advices
on how to do handstands
or something like that.
- The 180 strategy, if you
google Gary Vee 180 strategy,
is the idea of, there's a saying
what's your two cents on this idea.
90 times a day on Instagram
you go to other people's accounts
in the things that you're interested in,
look at their content and leave a comment
that's meaningful.
Not like them with the
hope they like you back,
follow, unfollow, all the bullshit.
No, no, meaningful comments
and then you start building
meaningful relationships.
- So before I get into my question,
I'm into making funny videos as well.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I have this combination
of calisthenics, sports,
and funny videos and
it goes to many topics
like even parenting.
- [Gary] Okay.
- I've done funny videos
about sports and stuff
and funny videos about friends
and it goes to many topics.
And I've done some videos for companies,
I've been trying to.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- I'm in negotiation with a company
similar to Best Buy in the States now.
- [Gary] Okay.
- And I made three videos for you,
I already DM on Instagram,
DRock and team Gary Vee.
I showed you two videos.
I made them really quick
'cause I was coming here
and it's shitty so I can remake them.
- [Gary] Okay, fine.
- And the third scenario,
I haven't made it yet,
but it's written and I just want to--
- [Gary] I can't wait to see it.
Send it.
- I want your advice on it or opinion.
- [Gary] Okay, I'll take a look, I will.
- So my question is how
can you go into the state
of not judging yourself?
- [Gary] Practice.
- And still keep going?
- Practice.
- Because I've one for
like a month and a half,
I've been focusing on
calisthenics and videos,
and I went silence in here.
- [Gary] Practice.
- But then it was gone.
- Practice.
(laughing)
(audience applauding)
You gotta practice.
You gotta read the
comment and play with it.
You suck, you're not funny.
Read it, read it, read it.
Now here's where it gets good.
If you read the comment from
somebody saying you suck
or are you judging yourself
or are you struggling with
the judgment of others?
Somebody saying it's stupid
idea that you're doing this
or a comment that's bad?
- [Man] I mean I didn't get
anybody saying it's stupid.
A lot of people like in it.
- Okay.
- But for me like continuing the work
for this month and a half,
month that I've been talking about
I went through like putting my workouts,
putting videos, putting funny videos--
- [Gary] And you burnt out?
- Huh?
- Are you burnt out?
You don't want to do it anymore?
- No, it's just, I for
some reason I slacked
and I didn't do anything.
I had this conversation with somebody
and just poof, went out.
- [Gary] Why?
- I don't know.
- [Gary] What do you think?
- I've been thinking of
maybe the combination of two
is not good sometimes
and it's slowing me down
and I'm not putting as
much content as I want to.
What do you think of the combination
like putting sports and
advices and funny videos?
- Good.
I think you might be impatient
because you went so hard
for a month and a half
and the numbers didn't get
to as high as you want them
by going too hard for a month and a half.
Right, because the reason
you're asking yourself
is this a good combo is
you didn't see the results
that you expected.
Let me promise you one way
that you can consistently
make yourself unhappy.
Having expectations.
(audience applauding)
I'm gonna move, thank you brother.
- [Man] Thank you very much.
- [Man] We got the microphone up at--
- I love it let's do it.
- [Man] We've got to pick up the top,
who has the microphone up the top?
Please start waving and ask your question.
Thank you.
- Love it, go ahead.
Hold on one second, it's not working.
Keep talking though.
Nope, still no.
There we go.
- [Mirela] Okay thank you, thank you Gary.
- Thank you.
- Thank you, I appreciate this.
My name is Mirela Sula,
I'm the founder of Global Woman
and I work a lot with women entrepreneurs
and most of them who come to the club
they never have done a
video live in their life.
And the issue here is that
they really like their private life
but they still want to be
successful in business.
What would it be your advice for all women
who are watching this video now?
How can they get that
confidence to break that fear
to take the phone and make a
live video in social media?
- There was something you said
that I didn't fully hear you.
Were you saying that
they're scared to do it
because they want privacy?
- Yeah, I don't know how they go together.
- They go together very easily.
I'm the most public
private person on earth.
You guys know nothing about my family.
I post 0.0 about my family.
You look them in the face and tell them
you don't have to post about your family.
- And what would be your
advice for them right now?
- To post.
(audience laughing)
Awesome.
What's that?
(man speaking off mic)
Okay.
Well managing a real life and
a side hustle that they love
is just about really looking at every hour
that you spend on what?
It's just balance.
It's just time management.
It's also what's the alternative?
People come to me all
the time and they say,
"Well Gary, I can't balance
my job that I have to do
"and my side coaching or whatever."
I'm like okay, then don't.
Then do both, then do both.
Of course it's hard,
everything's fucking hard.
I love you too, go ahead.
Hi.
All right, I'm gonna go over here.
Oh go ahead, go ahead, you're good.
- Hi Gary, my name's Kai.
- [Gary] Hi.
- First of all I just
want to say thank you
for living your truth and
just speaking it to everyone
and inspiring us all.
- [Gary] Thank you Kai.
- I'm a musician from the UK
and I kind of fell into
a business here in Dubai
called The Bite Club and
we promote restaurants.
Since doing The Bite Club we
do about six events a week
and so I'm meeting hundreds sometimes,
thousands of people daily, weekly
and I found that I've
got lots of good ideas
and I'm trying to catch
up with people that I meet
and I've also realized I'm a connector.
- [Gary] Love.
- But in all the platforms
and all the people I meet
and all the ideas and all the stories,
I don't know if there's a platform
you can possible recommend to schedule
or to help curate ideas and content,
because as a entrepreneur or small team,
it's great to create the content
but actually getting it
edited and you know cut down
and everything, like even today
I've taken loads of videos
but once it's edited where do you start
to churn out the 25 that
you recommend a day?
- Where do you post it?
- No, like do you recommend
like Planoly or HootSuite
or any scheduling apps
to help become a team
whilst you build a team.
- No.
I think you should open
Twitter and post a photo.
Let me tell you Kai where
everybody screws up.
People look for efficiencies
where what's needed is context.
My friends let me promise you
how not to do social media.
If you post the same exact
photo with the same exact word
to all 10 of the prominent platforms
they won't act the same way.
You have to write the copy and
you have to edit the content
for the psychological nature
and the utilitarian
nature of the platform.
For the 31 minutes you
save by hitting one button
and blasting it out, you're
wasting actual growth.
- So you would recommend
because I'm learning to be still also
and just take time to balance,
so let's say it was one
hour a day to just sit
and post individually.
- Well let me rephrase, sure.
- Okay.
- Yep.
whatever gets you the post,
I post my content.
Do you know busy I am?
I post it, I write it, I reply to you.
Every reply you ever got
ever from Gary V is me.
Not an intern, me.
(audience applauding)
That's why I have a team Gary V account
and other accounts in
case we want to engage
where I'm not, but if it's me, it's me.
If I have time, you have time Kai.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] You're welcome.
- [Irina] Hi.
- Hi.
- [Irina] Hi Gary.
My name is Irina and I want to tell you
I'm consuming your content
for more than 10 years now.
- [Gary] Wow.
- Yeah I look young but. (laughing)
- Yeah, I've gotten old.
Thank you so much.
Honestly that means a lot, right?
Like think about it, 10 years.
Talk about like you know,
but go ahead thank you.
- Yeah, more than 10 years.
Yeah so I think you're very
special and I love you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I think if you have
more people listen to you
the world would be a better place.
- [Gary] That's the plan.
(laughing)
- You're like a motivational speaker
but a very, very cool one.
- [Gary] Okay, thank you.
- Okay.
So this is about my love to you
and you always say about giving
so I want to give you my present.
Present to you, it's my business
and if you even like look at it after
whenever you have time--
- [Gary] Come on, bring it.
- Oh, really?
- Yes.
(audience applauding)
Okay, she's running.
- Oh my god.
- You can.
Thank you.
- Give me a hug.
- Oh, wow.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- And now the question, right?
- D Rock.
- [Irina] So basically.
Go ahead.
- [Irina] This product is offline right.
- Okay, offline.
- You're all about online, right?
I mean you not because
you started with wine,
but anyways the thing is it's
difficult to get investment
'cause everyone loves to
talk about online now.
- [Gary] No it's not.
Millions of people are
getting investment offline.
- Okay 'cause it's a vision board
and whenever a go to an investor--
- [Gary] I love that.
How many investors have you gone to?
Yell me the truth or I'll get mad.
- 12.
- [Gary] 12?
- And they all saying oh, if
you do online version of it--
- [Gary] That's 12.
- But everyone wants online version,
but online version doesn't work.
- No, no, you're saying everyone,
you're talking about 12 people.
- Okay.
You're talking about hundreds yeah,
i have to go to hundreds.
- Maybe thousands, maybe thousands.
(audience applauding)
And maybe you should go to people,
maybe you should do a
little research on Google
for people that invest in things
that aren't online businesses.
- But can I have your
exact opinion, sorry.
This is a vision board kit.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Oh, okay.
(audience laughing)
But do you really love
it or you just say to?
- I really love it.
Vision boards sell.
- But it doesn't exist, I created it,
nobody sells vision boards.
- [Gary] People sell vision boards.
- Nobody sells vision boards.
- [Gary] Go to Pinterest
people sell vision boards.
- No, it's a vision board kit.
- [Gary] People sell vision board kits.
- It's not like that, they
don't have the boards.
- [Gary] Yours might be
your might be better.
- Mine is much better.
- [Gary] Good.
- They sell it online,
A4 papers, it's stupid.
- [Gary] I'm sure, I love it.
- Thank you, you're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Hi Gary.
- Hi.
- My name is Mariela and I'm
a first-time business owner.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- Actually I worked for about 10 years
in the corporate world.
I broke a lot of glass
ceilings around the world.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- And especially as a
mom, first time mom--
- [Gary] I love it,
let's clap it up for her.
(audience applauding)
- And I wanted more so I
started my own business
and now I feel that I'm stuck.
I love the process, the money is fine
because I worked really hard
and the business is fine.
It's not making a ton of money
but it's making enough for me
to continue with the process
and I want to continue but I feel that
the growth is slowing down.
- [Gary] Are you micromanaging?
- What's that?
- I try to do that less and less
but I feel that where I'm
stuck is in my training
and my learning.
- You yourself, that's awesome.
- Yeah, so I feel--
- That's good, that's the
most solvable part of it all.
- [Mariela] How?
- Well there's something
called the internet
and on the internet there's
a website called Google
and YouTube and you can
literally type in anything
that you think you're stuck with
and then somebody will
give you content for free.
- Yes, I definitely, I'm always there
but I find it so overwhelming.
I know identified that
I don't have mentors,
so that's one thing but I am at loss
and overwhelmed of the
amount of information
and my business is running and it's going
and I'm also involved so it's--
- What are you most unhappy about?
That it's not growing more?
- No, not the business.
I feel that I can still give more
and I can still learn more.
I'm so hungry good to learn
more, but I feel that--
- [Gary] Sometimes people are patient,
like eight weeks 15 year old who I love,
and sometimes they're impatient
for everybody in Dubai
to collect football cards.
Sometimes people are impatient
for their side hustle
to get big enough so they leave.
Sometimes people are impatient
for quenching their thirst for learning.
- I understand but when you were stuck,
have you ever felt stuck?
- [Gary] Nope.
- Really?
- [Gary] Really.
You know why?
- Why?
- [Gary] 'Cause I don't judge myself.
(audience applauding)
- But haven't you been in a situation
where you just don't know what to do?
- [Gary] Every day.
- [Mariela] Right, so what
do you do when that happens?
- I make it up and a pick one.
I love losing, I love
going through the process,
I learn that way.
Every day I have a situation,
the reason I'm good at business
now is I've done it so much,
I have such pattern
recognition, I can do this,
but other things happen
to me all the time.
Like every day.
I pick something and if it
goes well, I'm like I knew it.
I pick something, it goes
poorly, it was D Rock's fault.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I take that loss and I keep evolving.
You might also not be stuck,
you might have decided you're stuck.
- Interesting, thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
How are you bro?
You're good, you're good.
Uh-oh, actually you're not good.
Hold on.
See, I was wrong.
Still, it's still not working.
- Okay yeah this lad
just wants to shout-out
his Instagram tag because
he forgot to earlier.
- [Gary] No problem.
- Yeah Gary, I forgot
to tell you the name.
- [Gary] Can you go
fast, you're long-winded.
- Grownupchild, that's my--
- Grownupchild, got you.
- Just the quick question on TikTok.
- [Gary] Yes.
- I know you've been shouting
out about it recently.
Where do you see it going in
the next three to five years?
- No idea.
- 'Cause I'm a bit confused
because at the moment obviously
it's like dancing videos
and yeah, like Instagram
obviously started as filters
and obviously I'm just wondering
where you see it going.
(audience laughing)
- I have no idea, I'm not Nostradamus.
- [Man] Okay, yeah.
- What I know is 1.5 billion
people are on it right now.
- Okay, so you're just saying go with it,
keep going with it and see what happens?
- What's the alternative,
what's the downside?
People value their time
when it's not valuable.
Of course go with it.
- [Man] Brilliant, thank you very much.
- You got it.
- [Sam] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [Sam] I'm good, how are you?
- Very good.
- My name is Sam and I am pro
calisthenics athlete as well.
Cheers to the athlete on the other side.
Actually I used to work as a cabin crew
almost for four years
but actually I liked it
only for a few months and then I decided
to start changing.
After four years I left
because I loved calisthenics.
I loved the way how
training is going with me,
everything, and then
almost like 10 months ago,
I started just like searching
how do I start on social media?
- [Gary] Okay.
- Yeah and for now I'm
just like posting normally
on Instagram and that's it.
- How many times a day?
- Hmm, a story, you can say like--
- [Gary] Not story.
- Not story, you can say
two or three times per week.
- [Gary] Mm-hmm.
(audience laughing)
- So basically I started,
I just like bought my domain,
I'm starting my website soon
and literally like two to three days ago
I made all the accounts on
almost all the platforms.
- [Gary] Good.
- Now I want to ask you something.
Actually I have problem,
which is like if I don't have a plan,
let's say if I want to go to Everest,
if I don't have a map,
I cannot go to the top.
- [Gary] That's bad.
- Yeah.
That's why I take too much
time to plan my thing,
what's your advice?
- [Gary] Why, that's the game, why?
- Because I feel like
if I don't know the way
how I would reach to the top--
- Yeah listen, this is why a lot of people
are not entrepreneurs.
Your framework is an incredible
number for an executive.
I need you to work for me.
It's unlikely that you'll
build anything successful
with that much fear of the unknown.
- So?
- [Gary] One of two things.
- Yes.
- Start practicing on
doing things without a map
or put the map down and
go follow somebody else.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- You understand?
That's your only two options, got it?
And listen to me, listen to me.
There is nothing wrong with
following somebody else.
There's nothing wrong with
being a number two, three,
four, this whole generation that everybody
has to be a founder and CEO
and entrepreneur is ludicrous.
It's ludicrous.
In the same way that everybody
should have been good
and went to college 20 years ago.
It's ludicrous.
So if you want it so bad ideologically,
you got to start going into
the forest without a map.
You gotta try.
If you're incapable you're
gonna have to take a step back
and say I'm gonna follow somebody else.
- Okay, thank you very Gary.
- All right, they're pulling me off.
I'm so sorry, I love you Dubai!
- Please, oh my god please,
Gary V I've been following
you for five years.
Please, I have visualized this.
I can't believe you're
right in front of me.
You were on my vision
board, I beg you please.
- You'll never believe
this they just told me
had you been following me for six years,
I could have, no, go ahead, go ahead.
Go ahead.
(audience laughing)
Go.
You were very loud before.
(audience laughing)
- I'm sorry.
It's still not on.
- [Gary] There you go.
- Okay, firstly I just want to say
I have visualized this moment for so long
for the last four or five years.
I think you're unbelievable.
Because of you I've got so
much more gratitude in my life
and I can't thank you
enough for that honestly.
So this is a really big moment for me
and I'm fighting for it
and I really appreciate you
and I want to say that
I wanna hug you after I talk to you.
Just one hug, two seconds, please.
- [Gary] Done.
- Thank you, okay, I love you.
(woman speaking off mic)
- [Gary] Don't worry, I'm staying.
You're not gonna lose me now, don't worry.
I'm waiting.
- You got me, here.
- [Gary] There we go.
- I moved to Abu Dhabi
when I was 20, I'm now 28,
I'm a teacher here.
I have a side business that I'm building,
before you judge me,
yes, I'm a life coach,
I don't have everything figured out.
I know I don't.
I'm using my experience of being an expat
to hopefully help people
in expat in their life.
- So you're not a life coach,
you're an expat coach
which I love, keep going.
You know why because
you're actually an expat.
- Yes I am an expat and
I have found a niche
where I really want to help people.
- [Gary] I like that, keep going.
- Where I didn't have,
I'm looking inside for my niche, right?
- Who do you think think Gary V is?
I'm the person the 12-year
old me was looking for.
- Yeah.
(audience applauding)
- I understand.
- And I took that from you
to look inside yourself
and your own experiences.
I'm kind of torn between,
a teacher full time, I'm
trying to build Nova Coach,
that's my business from expat teachers
but also my energy has now
been taken away a little
because I'm obviously still teaching
but I've been now implementing
a coaching program
into my school in Abu Dhabi
around building a culture
of innovation and trust,
which is actually turning out
to be pretty unbelievable.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- And I'm kind of torn
between what do I do,
like I know I need to leave teaching,
I'm a incredibly passionate person
and I know I'm meant
to be doing something--
- [Gary] Else, okay.
- Coaching expats or building
culture of innovation
and trust in schools.
- [Gary] Great.
- I'm stuck, I don't know
where to put my energy though
because like right now my
content is a bit stale online
because I've been pumping
my energy into teaching
and also building this
culture of innovation
and trust in my school.
- [Gary] Your actions are speaking.
- Sorry I'm like...
- No, no your actions.
- My actions?
- Your answer is what you're doing.
Right now you're more passionate
about this culture thing
because you've now innovated
and said wait a minute,
maybe this is what I need to be doing.
- But I'm extremely passionate
about the expat experience.
- [Gary] No shit.
- Yeah.
You can tell if you heard
my heart beating now,
it'd be crazy, sorry I'm just so nervous.
- I love that you're passionate about that
but your actions are speaking about this
so see this through and see
where it takes you and---
- So just produce content as much
as I want on my platforms--
- My dear, I'm so glad
we got your question in.
This is what everybody does.
You're judging.
- [Woman] Myself.
- Correct.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Do six months of this thing
and if it doesn't feel good anymore
start doing more expat--
- Because I'm getting a good
response from the school
and from the teachers around creating
a culture of innovation and trust
because the buzzword
right now is innovation,
but people are afraid to take risks.
So we need to create trust in schools.
- Yep.
I don't know why you're judging yourself
for not finishing the expat thing
when this thing came, see that through.
I know you liked it.
- So should I change my content online?
- [Gary] Yes.
- To culture of innovation and trust?
- Yep.
I don't know if you heard this,
but for seven years I only
put out content about wine.
Do you remember that part?
- But I feel disloyal to the followers.
- Do you remember that part of my story?
- [Woman] I do, yeah, yeah.
- So that's the answer.
- Okay, so it's okay to change.
It's okay to evolve.
- [Gary] I got good news for you.
Everything's okay.
- Okay thank you.
I love you so much.
- You're welcome, come on, come on.
All right Dubai, thank you so much!
(audience cheering)
Thank you!
(rock music)